[Music]
ever since I can remember I've always
looked up to you when we were little
girls I thought you were so cool I did
everything I could to dress and act
exactly like you because I wanted to be
like you now that I have my own taste in
clothes obviously better taste I want
you to know I still consider you an
incredible role model you've shown me
what being a sister means being a sister
means bringing chicken noodle soup when
she feels sick it means fighting over
who gets to ride shotgun and sometimes
letting her win being a sister means
listening when she needs to vent about
something stupid her friend did teaching
her how to talk to boys and teaching her
how to talk [ __ ] about boys when they
break your heart
helping her with schoolwork you master
years ago and by mastered I mean got a
c-minus on teaching her how to drive
both when the cops are looking and when
the cops aren't looking being a sister
means picking her up from a party when
she's had too much to drink being a
sister means a lot of different things
but most importantly it means you always
have a best friend thank you for helping
me grow from a girl into a woman I love
you
[Music]
[Music]